la salle est d'alarmé tirée à l'hôpital
de marmande dans le lot-et-garonne ce
vendredi une centaine de manifestants se
sont réunis pour alerter sur le manque
de main d'oeuvre au service des urgences
un service qui fonctionne uniquement
avec des remplaçants au cours de l'été
le docteur maillard chef du service à
démissionner les habitants de marmande
obligé aujourd'hui à ne pas parcourir
plusieurs kilomètres afin de se rendre
dans les hôpitaux et grandes villes
voisines
que l'hôpital de marmande et il assure
les soins pour une population d'environ
80 mille habitants son bassin de
recrutement et de 80000 habitants et
ensuite les urgences qui ferment même
partiellement la nuit c'est un accès aux
soins qui n'existe plus à ce moment là
voilà pourquoi c'est grave 80000
habitants pas d'accès aux soins la nuit
et pourquoi on est comme ça parce qu'on
n'a pas de médecin urgentiste on
fonctionne avec des intérimaires voir
pas d'intérimaires du tout et on en
arriver à la situation où on est là est
actuellement n'a plus qu'un seul médecin
titulaire qui en arrêt maladie donc nous
avons nous tournons actuellement qu'avec
des intérimaires ce geste de mme harman
et en plus de ça on a sorti des internes
qui assure et aussi des gardes aux
gestes de marmande
donc là dans l'avenir si on n'aura plus
que nos deux médecins de garde 24 heures
sur 24 pour assurer les soixante dix
passages journaliers et 6 cents sur
l'année on a besoin simplement d'être
considérés au même titre que les
personnes qui vivent à bordeaux
justement parlé de bordeaux dans des
grands dans les centres urbains on a
besoin nous la ruralité d'avoir vraiment
tout ce qu'il nous faut c'est à dire cet
hôpital qui est vital pour nous et ça
c'est important alors je dirais on est
encore plus qu'avant données